all right old school old school
where'd you grow up where you're from
originally i was born in detroit
but my family moved out here when i was
six months old
and tell me about your family you have
both your parents
yeah um it's
two boys three girls uh
my parents met in church
my father's saying uh singing in the
choir my mother played the piano
they got married he was 17 she was 16
15.
most uh only thing i remember
is my family like the party
my father had five brothers they were
all professional painters
my father he told me at a young age
that i needed to have a
strong work deck ethic
my mother she
told me and my brother she taught us how
to
do everything we needed to do she's here
because
there are you might know that i always
have a woman to do it for you
but they also told us
whatever we wanted to do whether it's
smoke or drink
smoke cigarettes or drink beer to let
them know
because they'd rather get it for us then
uh see us out there on the street
hustling in front of liquor stores
well me i uh
i've always been my mother said
i was a little hope ever since she knew
me because i've always been chasing
women
i always loved pretty women and
as i grew older into my teenage years
i dress like this because my father
dressed like that
and i want to just like his father and
my appearance
draw girls to me so that made it easy
and over the
a period of time
some of the women even taught me
what i should say to women that would
attract them
so they helped me with my game they made
my job real easy
yeah yeah they do
i got in believe it or not i i wasn't
in the game until uh
about 15 years ago
there was a what we call a track
which is a name for where the street
the the hose walk
well it started
out i just see all the whole standing
out there up and down the corner the
pills be out there
and i like the the way
the stuff that they had but
unfortunately i was addicted to drugs
that's all i cared about
until uh what we call a renegade
she was prostitute but she didn't have a
man
and she asked because she asked me why
are you out here watching
all these pimps hoes watch your neck
honey when you can be getting your own
money
she said you're not a bad looking man
when she said money i i just i just
thought she was gonna give me something
unfortunately uh i was watching i was
getting paid by the pimps to watch the
whole
i was getting paid by the holes not to
tell on and i was getting paid
by the tricks that were out here on
vacation
that didn't want to be seen with a
prostitute
so i was making two or three hundred a
night
and i was satisfied with it until that
night china
came up to me and told me that after we
talked for a few minutes
she took me and rented me a motel
and she said she gave me about 1100
she said here daddy hello
i didn't know what it was for uh
i was just happy she said i'm going back
to work
uh what you want me to bring bring you
back i said
i'm thinking i was naive i'm thinking
did i want something to drink or either
something she said no how much you want
me to make
i didn't even know what to tell her i
just yeah whatever you bring me
so she left at night and didn't come
back to the room
until the next morning and when she came
back
she had two more females with her
she said daddy uh these are my walking
laws
i didn't even know what that mean i
thought that was some gay [ __ ]
but she said no they work for you
and they see she said here's
you got to make phone call well i got to
go
i'm just calling the dope man
she said no you got you had 24 hours
to serve day x 10.
what you mean surfing i ain't taking no
food tonight
she's like no daddy she gets she started
getting mad at me
because i didn't know and she figured
that since i was out there with them
every day i was learning from them
i was paying attention i was catching
bits and pieces you know they taught me
about
what a green [ __ ] is uh
a renegade turnout
and but they didn't teach me about
having the responsibility
of calling x duel
well anyway i make the call and it finds
out
is the 24-hour period
gives him an opportunity to buy him back
from you
and uh
things things were real good
i started getting spoiled and the more
i got around and was there they taught
me how to manage them
it took me farther away from the drugs
my addiction became
money because i've seen the other pimps
with uh nice cars
burnt coats
i still didn't have my hose had cars and
i didn't
but i didn't know that
i could have took one of them i could
have just said that's mine
the object of the game is
you i know you probably heard the term
gorilla pimp
all that well
those i consider those guys
the kind that they don't have
the uh ability
to communicate with a person
to get them to understand that what you
want her to do
a gorilla a good pimple
well his girls will want to do
work for him and not feel like
they have to
because a lot of these girls out here
now
as you know on the news they've been
kidnapped from other states
and they're forced to do it that's a
gorilla pimp
because they fear him for their life and
they have a bunch of they they
attack them psychologically and
physically
but i don't even think they know what
they're doing
they just know you can put some women
out there on the street threaten them
and you get money but there's a
structure
yeah there's a structure
your we have what they call the bottom
[ __ ]
she's your number one girl
she's in charge of all the discipline
okay and uh that way
when she beats her ass
you're cleaning from it you can go and
love her up make her feel like she you
love her
i didn't do this to you but
it also sends a message to her that if
she keeps growing up
what she got to face
so in my game when i was really out
there
uh i had no trouble
china was my bottom [ __ ] she made sure
everything
ran smooth what happened to me
i was trying to do two too many things i
was trying to
uh pimp girl sell dope smoked dog
and i got caught up my girls with taffy
and shashi
two white girls and china dogs
well i got locked up and uh
while i was gone i get out and i find
out that uh sassy
was dead
and i want to know what happened
come to find out she knew some young
gang bangers
that she liked to hang around with after
i left in the jungle
and she went over there they have
i guess have some fun with him
and he beat her to death
with a ball pen hammer in his mama's
house
and then he rode around with her body in
the
trunk of the car her car for five days
before the police sassy i mean taffy
put out a missing person for her in the
car
because they weren't trusters but
they had been on the same team for so
long
that they really did consider the
self-family
so when she went missing she was worried
about they got their riding around
and when they put up the uh
stolen report the apb
he riding around for a week with a dead
body
in a stolen car he didn't care
but that hurt me and my mother
found out about it and she said you have
daughters sisters nieces
how would you feel if somebody had one
of us out there on the street
you wouldn't like it and
she was right i tried to back i backed
away from it for a lot
oh good but it's hard
when women are coming
to you and to asking you
which we call choosing would you be your
supporter
i think well you know what that entails
right
she said yeah she said yeah i know
because
when a woman chooses she can't choose
a pimp and be broke
whatever she has in her pocket
which at least has to be over three four
hundred dollars
minimum whatever she has and that's only
because she just got started
whatever she has they have to do what we
call breakouts
break themselves you have to give you
everything she got
that's showing the offering that she
really wants to be with you
because if she chooses you
excuse me she is
either running from a guerrilla pimp or
she got somebody that he don't know what
he's doing
only thing he's looking at the free
money aspect of it
but it's not free
i smoke too many cigarettes
it's not free
because you have to
make appearances well i did
excuse me i drop
them off tell them then i'll be back
and they didn't know it
but i was coming back in between times
just to make sure that it was all right
because i know
how a lot of times prostitutes get
snatched up off the streets
they get picked up supposedly for dates
and uh they ended up they do what
they're supposed to do
because money comes first this is the
business deal
they the guy's gonna pay them the money
but then they turn around
after they finish and beat them and rob
them and take the money back
that's why
that's why a lot of prostitutes today
they they have what they call drivers
but they're glorified by guys
they work for pam
you know it give them uh something but
empowerment because he's watching an
investment
but he's also responsible for that
investment so basically
it's like he's putting his shelf on the
line
uh because if he let something happen to
her
you may as well leave town because that
means you ain't get your job
there's numbers if there's a problem
he knows how to get in contact with her
people
or other people that can come if he's
outnumbered but
a lot of people forget about that see if
you be true to the game the game will be
truly you
i acquired some very nice things
because off the backs of other women
like i said i tried to get away from
them
just the other day one thing
she's a entertainer
so we talked
we ended up she stayed at the motel with
me
and she said i chose you
because of your personality
where you carry yourself i wasn't even
trying to get at her
i meet a lot of women
a lot of young women
that they approach me
and they want to be with me
but i'm i'm 60 years old and you're in
your 30s
first thing come to my mind is
i i ask them i say you ain't got no guy
as good as you look
what's wrong with your man that are uh
where you are
but it's funny because they all come up
with the same lie
my boyfriend cheated on me with my best
friend
you i think
i'm flattered by compliment some of them
i really attracted you
i'm tired i really want to i'm at the
age i want to settle now
uh that's hard to do because
i even when i was married i cheated on
my wife
i just like i'm like basketball i like
31 flavors
you know what i'm saying and
i want somebody that's gonna be real
with me
somebody wants me for who i am
but these women make it hard
because they're trying to run again
they're looking for sugar daddy
and i'm looking for one that pay like
she's right
you know i say we can work together to
help each other or we can work against
each other
because if you're trying to use me i'm
way older than you
some of the stuff you're doing i don't
trying to do other than forgot about
you know so it's hard to
run a scam and they make it so obvious
i think a lot of young women are
moving towards having older men
because these young dudes they don't
know how to treat them
they don't know how to talk to them
and they uh in some cases
if they're real pretty
they nine times out of ten and she's
pretty
all her friends gonna be pretty so he's
gonna be trying to get at him
on the slide not because he got no gain
it's just cause he's a horn toad and
if somebody is treating you nice
and and put their emotions into you
i believe uh
you should give it back that that's one
of the reasons i
turned depending because me and my wife
my kid's mother we were together all
through junior high in high school
i went into the marine corps she wanted
to be i was going to make a career out
of it
she didn't want to be a
military wife so i gave up my military
career
to keep my marriage as soon as you get
out
she she's so
i was deeply hurt i'm a vengeful person
i'll be the first one that made it
you heard me i'm gonna hurt you deeper
i'm gonna [ __ ] your friends your sisters
anybody close to you and i did it
i did it because
she left going to school
one day after i got out of the drug
program
she left going to school one day at a
college
a career college and she come back home
with monkey bites all on her neck
you come home to your husband
with monkey bites on i tell you you just
made it hard
for all the other women out there cause
they're gonna pay for your mistakes
not physically but emotionally
because in the game
it's a matter of winning the person's
confidence
and once you get the confidence and you
get their trust
once you get that trust
if they don't even assume
that you're using them
and that that it got to the point where
it was a little too much for me
but to this date
you might see me within a week's time
you might see about 10 or 15 different
women
hold you i'm 60. yeah
so is the basis of the pimp and
prostitute relationship
is it based on something like the father
well
father-daughter relationship you know
some uh some prostitutes
are looking for a father figure father
figure
because their father
wasn't there it all boils down to
they want someone they want to feel like
they've been luck they really loved
and their self-esteem
nine times out of ten and so low that
the first person that be kind to them
they fall in love with them
that's a little i'm actually exposing
too much gain
because game is to be sold and not joke
but
i got nieces
sister well my sister's day up in a but
there's holes out there in the 60s
70s been out there since they're 12
years old
that's all they know how to do you know
and for a while they throw out
they thought crack to put pimps out of
business we'll just say
it decapitated a third of our work
workforce
because they were
i think i have after they got addicted a
lot of them
they couldn't afford to get a pimp that
money because
the craving for the dope
always had you want more and more so
the more they gave him the less they
could get high
that's why like i told you uh i was
getting paid
by the pimps to wash the hose and the
hose got to tell them
because they were sneaking and getting
high when they should have been out
there trying to get money for
the pimp but i didn't have no investment
in it
i was just looking for a quick buck and
it's uh
i i don't know you for me to be
the type of person that i am
to be in that profession because in
order to be a
pimp you know or damn you have to be
heartless only thing you're concerned
about is money
but i don't think it's wrong
i don't think it's right if you know you
care about somebody
even though let's say y'all do stepped a
lot
across the line and you started the pimp
started
feeling emotional eventually
the money is gonna stop coming from her
because
he don't want nobody else [ __ ] her
that much
and then that's going to actually do
more damage to the relationship because
he's used to having a certain
amount of cash flow and it's
not going to be there that's
like
a real a a whole is never supposed to
walk
next to her pimp she's never supposed to
ride in the
front seat of the car with him
[ __ ] belong in the back of you
guys used to get mad people couldn't
understand
when the hoes be walking down the street
and other pimps the owner
they said man leave that leave that
dudes girl up [ __ ]
that's my job that's what i do for a
living
bust [ __ ]
so
you can't uh
make a point express a point of view on
something you don't understand
it may look like it's foul because i
know that's his woman
but that's extra money for me
so of course i'm gonna go after her
not let not as much but
i'm the type of person uh
you can show me better than you tell me
because women come and they talk
about their feelings
towards you well
those are just words if you really love
me
you'll help me get what i need
i need something wrong coming on my car
i need that it always starts off
just with little things
i just need some keep in mind
she's thinking that you really
care about her so
she's willing to do it you are a man she
want to
help you
and then uh
reality kicks in
and when all the other wife watching
come around she starts here well if you
love me why are you with all them
give me your sisters
you know sisters when you out there on
the track
you you help your sister if
you can help her young birth turn the
same trick at the same time
that way y'all keep an eye on each other
but in reality that's twice the money
he gotta pay twice and half the time
he ain't gonna get what he wanted he
didn't get
the service because they can start
switching up i'm trying your job
can't nobody do nothing to you that you
don't allow them to do
and if people you allow people to
uh work you you got what you got coming
i'm uh i'm about
at the end of my story but
the uh skin we have a model
that we live by himself holds down
put ten toes down and never let the
bottom of your feet hit the ground
in other words that means you start
walking
and you keep walking until
you get what i want
that you want to make me happy give me
money that makes me happy
and if i'm about somebody that's willing
to do it
good for me a hard day's work for them
how does karma work into all this karma
karma because what you just explained
sounds like you're using these people
yes these women
oh karma comes back in in different ways
karma comes back when you least expect
it and it might not even come back on
you
but somebody close to you
i feared that
because i would never want
somebody in my family to get hurt
because of what i did to somebody else
but the only rule
in the in the streets is there are no
rules
if you're out there for survival
people nowadays they used to be on their
own
fees nowadays
because most people are well a lot of
people that
i used to feel like uh
we weren't friends but we're real good
associates
we watched each other's back
now they'll set you up if you don't give
them what they want
they'll set you up to be raw make up a
lie
tell them somebody you care about them
that you did something
uh and you didn't only they doing it out
of spite
my father has a statement he made a
statement that i live by
they say why why you keep a gun on him
the police might catch you well i'd
rather
for the police catch me with it than
somebody that don't like me without it
i don't like to be turning
watching over my shoulder uh
every time if you go down
it it's going to be a really bad issue
and now on the other hand
i try to uh
avoid the situation i know i have a
temper
i can't argue we start arguing i say
[ __ ] it we don't fight anyway i'm gonna
take off
but as i got older
i start retaining some of the
information that
my parents taught me
you treat people the way you want to be
treated
and if somebody comes up to you
and he just wants to get his point
across
it doesn't have to be about something
you did
he's pissed off about something
something's going on in his life
and you just have to
happen to say something to him at the
wrong time
so he's going to take all this
aggression genre on you
well for me
i i try to listen if it's not
too rambunctious i'll try to listen let
you shake maybe you just need to be
but then
if we have a disagreement and i want to
hear
i'm going to walk away but if you follow
me after i walk away i'm not responsible
for my actions
i ran into a cis situation of the night
god came and then this was about a lie
about a lie this chick came
and had young come up to me for the gun
she said something she's trying to be
our heart because she know he got a gun
but he didn't know how many guns was on
him
these weren't uh people that
that's their job that's because
i have report with people people
care about me they didn't even know what
was going on
so i tell people just because they look
like i'm by myself
i don't mean them by myself
the gaming get so crazy now
that these young
wannabe pimps that's kidnapping these
girls
have them out there with
no clothes on basically
you make him look like a hoe everybody
knows what you're doing
i i have had
and i just said i i i
watch a few people's bags but
to the ordinary person you don't even
know what they're doing
but you know they're just walking down
the street going somewhere
whereas these young guys they're trying
to get
fast money and they figure hey if i
could see her person
and the titties and all that all she got
on this
uh uh she threw um
jumper i see everything that's
advertisement
so that makes stem won't get picked up
faster
man you have no sympathy
like you said karma that's gonna come
back to bite you in the ass
because god don't like ugly
how many girls do you have now three
three girls and they uh
they've been with you how long
two of them have been with me
for about five minutes i just got back
into it
and that's because they needed a sponsor
do you guys stay they stay in a motel or
they have
yeah nobody ready what is that
none of the girls or pimps have
permanent residence
well
the rules have changed since back in the
day
it was a time for them to get to motel
y'all stayed in the same motel building
you get rooms but
the hoses stay in they get room
for them to bring the trick to and then
the pimp got this on now
inside of uh desperation
uh believe it or not some of these hoes
feel
safer in a hotel where they stay
because uh
they they scared their pills these
these guys really aren't pimples they
i don't even know what to call them show
you how immature they are
there's a there but
probably on saturday nights on figaro
you can't go down that street because
pig guys are circling around circling
around
trying to look at the hole so i want to
buy some [ __ ] some just
perverts and
they driving down in the middle of the
street doing doughnuts
but you're a pimp yeah how can
you supposed to lead by example your
appearance daddy that running around
here
tennis shoes jeans and white t-shirts
doing donuts in the street
but you call yourself a pimp
man they're giving the game a bad name
they get a gaming bad name by the way
they're dressed
by their actions
just like your whole is supposed to
represent you you have to represent them
then that draws other hoes to you
you look good they don't hear nothing
about you being a gorilla [ __ ]
yeah that's that's a good image compared
to
what they get they don't have a problem
choosing
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
treat people the way i want to be
treated
because like we talked about with karma
what i did which was
i never beat no on
on my whole i didn't believe in that
that's what
the vitamix is for she
she do the discipline according to
the offense just like in court
it's at her discretion
and um so i have
i don't have a gift of conscience
because the women
that come to me that's volunteers
i didn't i didn't pursue them
yeah all it is they just need a little
guidance
and they feel comfortable with me i
don't talk loudly
uh i don't thread no it's almost like
because they're doing this kind of work
they can't really get a
real romantic relationship going so this
relationship is almost
is a replacement for that then yeah
and they know they know if they've been
in the game
length of time they know the rules of
the game
now there are some pumps that
give him a bad name that
they falling in love with their health
and
they all can only work on shutting day
but don't get mad
when your bank account is short
because i ain't loaning you [ __ ]
you know going out there checking on
those is a stressful job
sometimes because you don't know if
they're on a date and they're gonna come
back
they all [ __ ] up or if they're dead
already
that's why you don't have feelings about
them
because if something happened to one of
them
and you're emotionally attached
you can't perform your job right
it's a rough way to make a living
it depends on how you look at it she
for me
i like i told you i i keep trying
and some of the girls the way they come
at me
is almost heartbreaking
and then some of them come
with that fake ass story
it they act like they're choosing
but they're trying to
actually call themselves pimping you
with a soft story
daddy i need them i want to make you
some money but
i want i can't dress like uh the way i
like to dress where i can really get out
and get my money
well you know what i'm gonna help you
out with that
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna take you to
a perfect spot
where a lot of traffic come to walk
through traffic come through
you can bend some corners and you make
some money real fast
but don't ever ask me for none of my
money
you're insulting my intelligence
all right old school yeah thank you so
much for sharing your story
i appreciate it i i just hope i can help
somebody
you know understand that
the life looks glamorous but it's
it's mostly done at night for a reason
for a reason
i was i was the children of the night
and hopefully i can help somebody
not be one
all right thank you so much man all
right thank you
that's a great talk thank you
you